we live in this weird age of people  really really hating biology yeah right  there's like this assault on biology and  this notion that the way we are  naturally wired is wrong I mean down to  the fact that  a man you know people literally saying a  man can be or is a woman and vice versa  like the most  you you can't kind of get more basic  biology than that let alone in terms of  actual behaviors and things that people  are attracted to or put off by and  interests you know they're always trying  to in certain Fields well we need to get  50 50 gender split in this or and it's  like bro you can't have  freedom and have Liberty and also expect  to get these equal outcomes and  everything because men and women are  fundamentally different